salut c'est romain demi l'idée de
culture générale j'ai deux petites
choses importantes à vous dire avant que
la vidéo ne commence première chose ne
regardez pas la vidéo comme ça avec du
pop corn
si vous voulez retenir ce que vous allez
apprendre dans cette vidéo vous devez
prendre des notes les études sur la
mémorisation ne laisse aucune place au
doute ne pas prendre de notes égal
oubliez donc faites moi plaisir ouvrez
une application comme google docs waver
note est noté ce qui est essentiel pour
vous au fur et à mesure seconde chose
que je dois vous dire la vidéo vous
allez regarder est extraite de ma
formation de culture générale qui
s'appelle culture express c'est une
formation qui permet d'acquérir
rapidement une bonne culture générale
sans se prendre la tête sans avoir à
lire ni à réfléchir elle couvre tous les
domaines de la culture générale elle
permet de maîtriser les connaissances
d'essentiel sur l'histoire de l'humanité
sur l'histoire de france en économie en
sciences politiques en psychologie en
sciences en littérature en art en
religion et enfin en philosophie ah oui
c'est important à la philo si ça vous
intéresse je tesi un coup d'oeil soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit en cliquant sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo voila
voila je vous ai dit ce que je voulais
vous dire maintenant je vous laisse
regarder la vidéo concentrez vous
préparez vous prendre des notes et puis
n'hésitez pas à m'écrire dans les
commentaires et moi je vous dis à la
prochaine
[Musique]
qu'est ce que la politique
tout est politique
mai 68 cette affirmation dépourvu de
nuances inspire la méfiance mais l'idée
derrière ce slogan de mai 68 à savoir
que la réalité humaine être
intégralement politique cette idée n'est
pas impossible à défendre en effet de
nombreux exemples simples montre que la
politique peut s'attendre à beaucoup de
choses l'alcool au volant est devenu un
problème politique en occident à partir
de la fin des trente glorieuses à la
même époque les violences conjugales
sont de plus en plus perçu comme un
problème de société alors qu'elle les
avait longtemps été considérés comme
relevant de la sphère privée autre
exemple la france fait partie depuis
2010 9 de la cinquantaine de pays qui
ont interdit la fessée qualifié dans la
loi de violence éducative ordinaire
c'est l'incursion de la politique dans
la vie y compris intime des citoyens
peuvent donc donner l'impression que je
cite la politique et s'intéresse à tout
comme l'a écrit machiavel la citation
complète est d'ailleurs tout n'est pas
politique mais la politique s'intéresse
à tout après les gens s'intéressent ils
à la politique autant qu'elle
s'intéresse à eux le slogan de mai 68
est révélateur de l'importance qu'à la
politique à l'époque la tension
idéologique de la guerre froide et le
développement de l'enseignement
supérieur décuple l'intérêt des citoyens
pour les affaires publiques les idées de
gauche en particulier sont alors
l'étendard de la révolte contre l'ordre
établi qui étouffe la jeunesse une telle
politisation paraît aujourd'hui révolue
al'inverse les observateurs dénoncent l
individualisme de la société de
consommation où chacun ne semble plus
concevoir son bonheur que dans le cadre
étriqué de sa sphère privée en clair les
intérêts personnels la famille les amis
et les relations sentimentales les
gourous du développement personnel en
font même un ingrédient du bien-être ne
vous intéressez pas aux choses que vous
ne maîtrisez pas laissez donc les
affaires publiques de côté et concentrez
vous sur votre propre destin individuel
ce conseil n'est pas dénué de sagesse
mais qu'adviendra-t-il d'une société
dont les membres ne se sentent plus
concernés par le destin collectif
dans cette leçon je vais répondre aux
questions suivantes comment définir la
politique quelle est l'essence de la
politique quels sont les jalons de la
pensée politique qu'est ce que la
démocratie qu'est ce que la droite et la
gauche
comment définir la politique je vais
d'abord vous donner une définition
générale du mot politique en partant de
son étymologie je préciserai ensuite ses
différentes dimensions
que signifie le mot politique le nom
comme un politique qui est féminin vient
du grec police et aux ailiers ce qui
signifie la cité la communauté urbaine
de l'antiquité grecque dont le
territoire et la population était grosso
modo de l'ordre de ceux d'une ville
moderne athènes la cité la plus
brillante de l'antiquité grecque
comprenait environ 250000 habitants au
vème siècle avant jésus-christ du point
de vue de l'étymologie la politique ce
sont donc les affaires de la cité
l'origine est grec du mot politique
m'inspire la définition à la fois la
plus générale est la plus simple la
politique c'est l'organisation de la vie
collective
cette idée piqué mais je voulais
explique quand même en quelques phrases
comme on l'a vu dans le premier module à
propos des chasseurs cueilleurs les
hommes sont des animaux entre kim est
capable de vivre en très grands groupes
comme une nation grâce à leur instinct
de coopération très développé seulement
une grande communauté d'êtres humains
n'est pas forcément harmonieuse les
membres peuvent s'aimer les uns les
autres mais ils peuvent aussi bien se
haïr et se faire du mal la méchanceté
des hommes et sans limite a écrit
aristote dans les politiques
autrement dit la violence peut éclater
au sein du groupe est ainsi menacé son
existence même d'où la nécessité
d'organiser et donc de pacifier les
rapports entre les individus afin de
pérenniser le groupe est organisé cela
signifie aux randonnées divers éléments
de manière à former un tout cohérent
c'est dans cette perspective que l'on
parle de l'ordre social bref l'enjeu de
la politique c'est de faire en sorte que
les hommes réussissent à vivre ensemble
afin d'assurer la survie du groupe
et comme le répétait alain boyer mon
prof de philosophie politique à la
sorbonne la politique ça commence à
l'échelle du couple il y a déjà un enjeu
d'harmonie et donc d'organisation quand
on vit à 2
quelles sont les différentes dimensions
du mot politique le mot politique est
androgyne il est la plupart du temps
dans la langue ordinaire féminin maison
l'emploi aussi parfois avec un peu de
snobisme au masculin vous pouvez lire le
politique sous la plume d'intellectuels
ou d'universitaires dans le détail le
mot politique recouvre trois dimensions
le français utilisent un seul et même
terme pour l'e3 mais l'anglais se sert
de trois termes voici les trois
dimensions le politique politi en
anglais et aux élites et y le politique
et le système politique dans son
ensemble
les structures institutionnelles et
idéologique du pouvoir politique par
exemple si je dis que l'économie doit
être soumise aux politiques cela
signifie que c'est au système politique
et non pas aux acteurs eux-mêmes de
déterminer les modalités de la
production et de la répartition des
ressources dans la communauté les
partisans de cette thèse et estiment que
les inégalités économiques mettent en
péril l'harmonie de la communauté c'est
pourquoi ils veulent que le pouvoir
politique contrôler l'activité
économique c'est par exemple une des
fonctions de la fiscalité elle
redistribue les richesses parmi les
citoyens pour réduire les inégalités qui
empoisonnent l'harmonie sociale
la politique politics en anglais et aux
élites et icf la politique et désigne la
compétition politique la lutte pour la
détention et l'exercice du pouvoir
politique c'est par exemple dans ce sens
que l'écrivain hemingway a dit je cite
chacun de mes contacts avec la politique
m'a donné l'impression d'avoir bu dans
un crachoir autant d'un côté il émane de
la noblesse du politique qui renvoie au
fait que la communauté maîtrise de son
propre destin autant de l'autre il n'est
pas rare que la politique inspire le
dégoût parce qu'à l'image du personnage
principal de la série house of cards les
hommes ambitieux qui s'engagent dans la
compétition politique abandonnent
souvent la probité de l'homme ordinaire
pour parvenir au pouvoir et pour le
conserver la politique est l'art de
mentir à propos a dit voltaire
enfin les politiques police ipo lycées y
en anglais et policies au pluriel
pongiste93 l'action politique plus
précisément les programmes d'actions
mises en place par une institution pour
atteindre des objectifs donnés c'est par
exemple dans ce sens que l'on parle à
des politiques publiques qui sont des
programmes d'actions propres à une ou
plusieurs autorités publiques le
singulier de cette acception du terme
politique et féminin on dit par exemple
une politique publique
c'est encore dans ce sens que l'on parle
de la politique économique qui recouvre
l'ensemble des interventions des
administrations publiques dont notamment
l'état dans l'économie enfin par
extension une politique est une
orientation générale suivie par une
entreprise la politique de remboursement
d'amazon par exemple ou même par un
individu qui peut suivre la politique du
moindre effort par exemple
quelle est l'essence de la politique par
essence de la politique je veux dire ce
en quoi elle consiste fondamentalement
si on ressort essentiel son principe
élémentaire il y à mes yeux trois
grandes réponses de référence à cette
question c'est d'un philosophe de la
grèce antique aristote dans ses
politiques celle d'un sociologue
allemand du tournant du 20e siècle max
de beurre et enfin celle d'un juriste
allemand du xxème siècle carl schmitt
quelle est la réponse d'aristote pour
aristote l'essence de la politique est
dans la nature humaine comme je vous
l'aï expliqué dans la deuxième leçon du
module de culture philosophique aristote
définit l'homme comme un animal
politique autrement dit il y a dans
l'homme un instinct politique des
dispositions innées qui le détermine à
organiser la vie collective l'existence
de cet instinct signifie que l'homme est
destiné par nature puisque la nature ne
fait rien en vain à s'associer avec ses
semblables dans le cadre de la cité
certes reconnaît aristote il existe des
animaux grégaires comme l'abeille c'est
à dire des animaux qui vivent en groupe
mais il ya une différence essentielle
entre l'homme et ses animaux l'homme
seul possède le langage or cette faculté
lui permet d'avoir une compréhension
bien plus profonde de la réalité il
identifie par exemple ce qui est
profitable nuisibles ce qui est juste ou
injuste puis elle lui permet d'imaginer
une nouvelle forme de la réalité humaine
à travers une nouvelle configuration de
la vie collective en clair le langage
ici puissant pour décrire le monde qu'il
permet de le transformer
et à quoi bon transformer le monde en
optimisant l'organisation de la vie
collective parce qu'il en va du bonheur
selon aristote l'homme ne recherche pas
seulement la société de ses semblables
pour surmonter sa condition naturelle
infirme c'est à dire pour survivre il
vit en société parce que c'est comme
cela qu'il s'épanouit qu'il est heureux
l'état c'est la communauté du bien vivre
et pour les familles et les groupements
de famille en vue du bonheur écrit
aristote dans les politiques sachez que
la distinction établie par aristote
entre d'une part l'homme qui serait le
seul animal politique et d'autre part
les animaux cette distinction est
aujourd'hui remise en cause par exemple
le primatologue frantz des vals fr
highness des oeufs w à haël ce
primatologue conclut de son analyse des
dynamiques sociales des chimpanzés et
les bonobos que les racines de la
politique sont plus anciennes que
l'humanité en effet le système de
coalitions possibles dans les sociétés
des singes rend leur organisation
sociale la très complexe
quelle est la réponse de max weber pour
max weber à l'essence de la politique et
réside dans l'autorité l'ensemble des
conduites humaines qui comporte une
domination de l'homme par l'homme relève
de la politique en clair c'est l'aspect
hiérarchique de l'organisation de la vie
collective qui est primordial
et le coeur du problème selon weber
c'est la légitimité les dominés ne
doivent pas obéir simplement en raison
de la contrainte mais parce qu'ils
acceptent le commandement par exemple
l'état français n'a plus besoin de
menacer les contribuables physiquement
voire de les faire payer l'impôt de
force comme c'était parfois le cas sous
l'ancien régime lorsque l'administration
royale voulait remplir les caisses
même si tant les principes que
l'efficacité du système fiscal français
moderne qui est un des plus efficaces
sinon le plus efficace au monde pour
lever l'impôt même citant les principes
que l'efficacité sont contestées
l'immense majorité des contribuables
consentent à l'impôt et règles d'eux
mêmes le montant exigé
toutes les dominations cherche ainsi à
éveiller et à entretenir la croyance en
leur légitimité écrit max weber dans
économie et société je vous expliquerai
dans la leçon suivante pourquoi et
comment selon max bert à l'époque
moderne l'autorité politique passe
essentiellement par l'état et quels sont
les types précis d'autorité auquel
l'état peut recourir
quelle est la réponse de carl schmitt
pour carl schmitt l'essence de la
politique et réside dans l'hostilité
plus précisément dans la distinction de
l'ami et de l'ennemi carl schmitt n'est
pas d'accord avec les penseurs de son
époque qui assimile le politique à
l'institution étatique de son point de
vue l'activité politique est antérieure
à l'état qui n'en est donc qu une des
expressions possible dans les faits
l'état n'a pas existé de toute éternité
il est une création de l'époque moderne
un instrument qui a permis aux
monarchies européennes à partir du
xvième siècle de mettre fin aux guerres
privé afin de rétablir l'ordre dans les
limites de leur territoire
pour carl schmitt l'essence de la
politique consisterait donc plus
fondamentalement dans l'association et
la séparation à divers degrés des hommes
ce qu'on simplifie en parlant de la
distinction de l'ami et de l'ennemi la
distinction spécifique du politique
c'est la discrimination de l'ami et de
l'ennemi a écrit carl schmitt dans la
notion de politique la dialectique de
l'ami et de l'ennemi se retrouvent dans
les apparences de l'activité politique
par exemple le discours politiques
privilégient souvent un vocabulaire qui
se rapproche de la rhétorique guerrière
les campagnes les affrontements verbaux
les bataille d'opinion le ton
imprécatoire dont usent les adversaires
alain à l'égard de l'autre tout cela
ressemble à s'y méprendre aux paroles
qui précède les conflits armés
l'activité politique semble donc se
substituer à une violence dont elle
conserve les stigmates par la
discrimination de l'ami et de l'ennemi
la politique évoque clairement le
conflit armé qui repose sur la même
discrimination
carl schmitt retrouve donc l'idée de la
célèbre formule du théoricien militaire
prussien klaus vite selon laquelle la
guerre et je cite la continuation de la
politique par d'autres moyens
quels sont les jalons de la pensée
politique je vais d'abord vous parler de
la naissance de la pensée politique en
occident j'évoquerai ensuite comment
cette pensée s'est libéré de l'emprise
de la religion chrétienne à partir de
l'époque moderne enfin je vous
expliquerai la mutation de la pensée
politique en ce qu'on appelle à la
science politique à partir du 19ème
siècle
comment la pente politique n'est t'elle
en occident la pensée politique née en
occident sous la forme de la philosophie
politique comme vous le savez la
philosophie occidentale est née en grèce
seulement elle ne s'intéresse pas
immédiatement à l'organisation de la vie
collective cela change à partir du vème
siècle avant jésus-christ avec la
prédominance d'athènes où triomphe la
démocratie l'esprit des penseurs se
tourner vers l'homme lui-même les
spéculations politiques ont une place
prépondérante dans l'effervescence
intellectuelle athénienne on développe
la rhétorique pour imposer ses idées
dans l'opinion publique on compare les
mérites respectifs des régimes
politiques et on imagine des
constitutions ont réfléchi à l'essence
de la politique
nombreux sont les sophistes et les
philosophes de l'époque qui s'exprime
sur le sujet mais loi de pareto oblige
seule une minorité sont devenus des
références de la pensée politique
occidentale si les idées de la
république l'utopie dans laquelle la
plate ont décrit l'organisation idéal
d'une société humaine je vous en ai déjà
parlé dans la deuxième leçon du module
de culture philosophique il résumé
détaillé est disponible sur le site mais
l'idée de culture générale si les idées
de la république de platon ont eu une
grande influence sur la philosophie
occidentale la pensée politique moderne
les laisse de côté parce qu elles ne
satisfont pas l'idéal de la science
moderne elle relève davantage de la
littérature l'oeuvre emblématique de la
naissance de la pensée politique en
occident nous la devons aux disciples de
platon ce sont les politiques d'aristote
pour avoir lu la république de platon et
les politique d'aristote j'ai été frappé
par la différence en fait cela n'a rien
à voir le propos d'aristote est en bonne
partie empirique et il a une rigueur
scientifique aristote justifie ses idées
il compare plein de constitution il
évoque de nombreuses de loi ainsi que
leur influence sur l'harmonie sociale il
fournit plein d'exemples historiques car
à ses yeux tout groupe humain est le
fruit d'une histoire qui explique entre
autres facteurs l'état de ce groupe pour
écrire une telle somme qui est un peu la
bible politique de l'antiquité aristote
a travaillé avec une équipe de
chercheurs qui a rassemblé beaucoup de
matériaux pour lui son objectif était
écrire un manuel pour former les futurs
législateur en effet la philosophie
politique et grecs n'étaient pas séparés
de la pratique aristote considérer la
politique en tant que discipline
intellectuelle comme une science
pratique c'est à dire qui guide l'action
d'où le grand pragmatisme de son propos
mais le lien avec la pratique ne se
limite pas au réalisme du propos les
philosophes grecs confronter leurs idées
à la réalité en devenant conseiller des
dirigeants qui les appelaient auprès
d'eux par exemple aristote a conseillé
alexandre le grand mais c'est parce
qu'il était son précepteur platon
lui-même malgré l'irréalisme de son
propos a été trois fois conseiller en
vin du tyran de syracuse d'abord denis
l'ancien puis denis lejeune
comment la pensée politique s'émancipe
tel de la religion le deuxième jalon et
la laïcisation de la réflexion politique
au cours du moyen âge en effet la pensée
politique était limitée par la
prépondérance de la religion est soumise
à la théologie puisque dieu était le
principe unique de l'ordre social il
n'était pas nécessaire de chercher à
optimiser l'organisation de la vie
collective
mais cette idée recul à partir du xvième
siècle c'est le fait de l'humanisme qui
désacralise la pensée l'auteur
emblématique de cette évolution et le
philosophe italien machiavel dont je
vous ai déjà parlé dans la leçon sur la
philosophie du moyen âge et de la
renaissance il théorise la politique
indépendamment de la doctrine catholique
et il fait preuve d'un grand réalisme il
a été diplomate avant de se mettre à
l'écriture dans le prince notamment il
énonce de façon implacable les façons de
gagner et de conserver le pouvoir il
faut estimer comme un bien le moindre
mal a écrit machiavel dans le prince
la laïcisation de la réflexion politique
progresse encore dans les siècles
suivants dans la prusse du xviie siècle
les sciences et caméral le terme
allemand caméra cas à m e ra désignait
le lieu où étaient conservés les déniers
publics les sciences caméra là théorise
le gouvernement de la société et en
particulier l'enrichissement de la
puissance publique comme je vous
l'expliquais dans la troisième leçon du
module de culture économique cette école
de pensée est animé par des hauts
fonctionnaires qui ont l'ambition de
développer une science de
l'administration au xviiie siècle les
écrivains des lumières critiques tant
l'influencé politique de l'église que le
despotisme ils défendent l'idée que la
société doit être organisée par les
hommes eux mêmes en vue de l'intérêt
général voltaire estime que cela passe
par la liberté et la tolérance qui
favorise la prospérité il fait l'éloge
du libéralisme anglais dans ces lettres
philosophiques pour sa part rousseau
imagine carrément de refonder la société
sur de nouvelles bases un contrat social
qui réussissent à garantir à la fois
l'égalité et la liberté des citoyens
enfin la pensée politique occidentale du
19e siècle est marqué par deux nouvelles
perspectives celle de tocqueville un
français qui montre avec l'exemple
américain que la démocratie est plus qu
un régime politique qu'elle est une
nouvelle société et puis il ya aussi la
perspective de marx un intellectuel
dissident prussiens qui avance que
l'organisation de la vie collective
n'est pas déterminée par la vie
politique mais par des facteurs plus
profond les rapports de force
économiques
comment la science politique se
constituent-elles la discipline qu'on
appelle la science politique se
constitue à partir du 19ème siècle sous
l'effet de deux évolutions principal sur
le plan intellectuel tout d'abord
l'idéal de la science moderne lequel
demande que l'on s'appuie sur des
observations rigoureuse et sur l'étude
des faits afin d'établir des lois cette
idée à la transforme la réflexion
politique en élevant ses standards de
rigueur intellectuelle cette mutation
s'inscrit plus généralement dans le
développement des sciences sociales à
l'époque
l'ouvragé fondateur de la science
politique telle qu'elle est conçue de
nos jours et le tableau politique de la
france de l'ouest publié en 1913 d'andré
siegfried est 6e gfr ed candidat
malheureux à la députation à plusieurs
reprises
ce prof de l'ancêtre de sciences po
tente de rationaliser ses échecs en
retraçant les votes aux élections
territoriales de la france de l'ouest
ses conclusions que je vous explique
dans la quatrième leçon du module se
fonde sur la psychologie et la structure
de la propriété
sur le plan concret ensuite la
démocratie s'installe en occident à la
fin du 19e siècle élection après
élection la concurrence est plus rude ce
qui fait naître une demande d'expertisé
en matière politique en france le
juriste et journaliste émile bootmii
fonde l'école des sciences politiques
l'ancêtre de sciences po à paris en 1872
son ambition est après le désastre de la
guerre contre la prusse de donner une
culture politique et administrative aux
nouvelles élites françaises en leur
transmettant un savoir davantage fondées
sur l'expérience et sur la pratique
plutôt que sur les théories juridiques
il ne voulait pas à créer une nouvelle
école de juristes la nouvelle école veut
rendre l'élite de la jeunesse française
plus à bizet plus sage moins exposée à
être dupe des charlatans politique écrit
emile bootmii dans une brochure de
l'époque
sont crédités à la même époque la london
school of economics and political
science qui est donc situé à londres
comme son nom l'indiqué en 1895 la
scuola cesare alfieri dcns socialiste
florence en 1875 cesare alfieri était un
diplomate italien renommé du 19e siècle
ou encore la school of political
sérieuse de columbia à new york en 1880
la science politique devient
véritablement une discipline
universitaire autonome après la deuxième
guerre mondiale reste alors une
association professionnelle des revues
un doctorat à une agrégation qui donne
accès au corps d'épreuve des universités
les centres académiques de la discipline
sont les instituts d'études politiques
sciences po paris mais aussi les
sciences po de province les facultés de
droit
d'autres formations universitaires en
histoire et en économie notamment et
enfin aussi les cours de sciences
économiques et sociales au lycée les
spécialistes de la discipline s'appelle
les politistes par rapport aux penseurs
des périodes précédentes leur méthode
est plus rigoureuse ils se servent de
sondages d'entretien biographique d'
analyse comparée d'observation
ethnographique ou encore de recueil
statistique enfin ce n'est pas très
important pour votre culture générale
mais vous pouvez également retenir qu'on
subdivise la science politique en quatre
domaines tout d'abord la théorie
politique ensuite la sociologie
politique la branche la plus importante
en troisième la sociologie de
l'administration et des politiques
publiques et enfin les relations
internationales vous l'avez compris la
sociologie et la source intellectuelle
principal mais la science politique
puise aussi dans l'histoire le droit la
philosophie ou encore l'économie
qu'est ce que la démocratie
je vais d'abord vous parlez de la
définition de la démocratie qui est
assez problématique je vous présenterai
ensuite les différentes formes de
démocratie enfin gevo créé les
principales limites de la démocratie qui
sont mises en évidence dans les
arguments des critiques de ce régime
politique
comment définir la démocratie le nom
commun démocratie vient des mots grec
dêmos le peuple et kratos le pouvoir à
suivre l'étymologie la démocratie et
donc l'organisation de la vie collective
dans laquelle le peuple détient le
pouvoir c'est à dire qu'il prend
lui-même les décisions qui concernent le
destin de la collectivité mais qu'est ce
que le peuple issu du latin populaire
qui signifie peuple ensemble des
citoyens le peuple désigne l'ensemble de
la population d'un état c'est à dire
tous ses citoyens soient tous les
individus qui jouissent des droits
civils et politiques il y à une
ambiguïté concernant la jouissance des
droits civils et politiques les femmes
et les esclaves qui n'avait pas le droit
de vote dans l'athènes de l'antiquité
faisait t-il partie du peuple les
enfants font ils partie du peuple dans
les démocraties modernes on peut donc
dire qu'il ya d'une part le peuple au
sens large l'ensemble de la population
d'un état comme dans l'expression le
peuple français et d'autre part le
peuple au sens précis c'est à dire tous
les individus qui jouissent des droits
civils et politiques dans l'état comme
dans l'expression la consultation du
peuple ainsi la démocratie et
l'organisation de la vie collective dans
laquelle c'est l'ensemble des citoyens
qui décident du destin de la
collectivité
cette définition est proche d'eux de la
célèbre formule d'abraham lincoln le
président américain qui a aboli
l'esclavagé en 1863 formule qui est
reprise dans l'article 2 de la
constitution de 1958 de la cinquième
république française le gouvernement du
peuple par le peuple pour le peuple
cette formule ajoute deux dimensions qui
ne sont pas crucial pour définir la
démocratie le gouvernement du peuple le
pouvoir politique et quelle que soit sa
forme consiste forcément à diriger le
peuple puisque le pouvoir politique et
celui qui permet d'organiser la vie
collective puis seconde dimension pour
le peuple le pouvoir politique n'est pas
forcément exercer dans l'intérêt du
peuple mais comme l'a expliqué aristote
pour être légitime le pouvoir politique
doit forcément viser les avantages
communs autrement dit l'intérêt général
l'idée que le pouvoir est exercé pour le
peuple et donc présupposés dans toute
forme de gouvernement qui se prétend
légitime par élimination l'allocution
crucial de la formule d'abraham lincoln
et par le peuple la caractéristique
fondamentale qui définit la démocratie
et donc que le peuple soit lui même aux
commandes or cela pose un problème
pratique si un individu unique peut
prendre des décisions comment une
multitude d'individus peut-elle y
parvenir faut-il forcément que tout le
monde soit d'accord pour considérer que
le peuple décide ou bien suffit-il
qu'une proportion de la population soit
d'accord le fond du problème vous l'avez
peut-être compris c'est que l'idée de
peuple fait passer une multitude
d'individus pour une entité unique avec
une volonté unique soit une entité dont
on imagine qu'elle pourrait prendre des
décisions comme un individu prend des
décisions
ce problème demande de revoir la
définition de la démocratie on peut
corriger l'idée d'unité de totalité
contenus dans la notion de peuple par
l'idée d'une proportion suffisante de la
population en pratique la majorité on
peut corriger l'idée d'une direction
collective qui paraît peu réaliste même
si les potentialités d'internet change
la donne par l'idée d'une direction
restreinte c'est à dire d'un nombre de
dirigeants limité avec ces révisions
pragmatique la réalité concrète de la
démocratie ne correspond pas à sa
définition théorique pour karl popper la
démocratie réelle se définit par la
capacité du peuple de choisir ses
dirigeants au moyen d'un scrutin
majoritaire l'élection serre dans cette
perspective à faire changer le pouvoir
demain sans violence elle représente une
menace de destitution qui incitent les
dirigeants à ne pas abuser du pouvoir
la démocratie ne fut jamais le pouvoir
du peuple elle ne peut pas l'être et ne
doit pas l'être écrit karl popper dans
la leçon de ce siècle
fondamentalement karl popper conçoit la
démocratie sous l'angle de la vie à
négative à c'est à dire qu'il se
concentre sur ce qu'il faut éviter la
question essentielle est à ses yeux
comment empêcher un dirigeant mauvais ou
incompétents de provoquer trop de
dommages
en conclusion vous pouvez retenir deux
définitions général de la démocratie
première définition la définition
idéaliste la démocratie et
l'organisation de la vie collective dans
laquelle s'élançant le des citoyens qui
décident du destin de la collectivité et
puis seconde définition la définition
réaliste la démocratie et l'organisation
de la vie collective dans laquelle la
majorité des citoyens choisis ses
dirigeants
quelles sont les principales formes de
démocratie les principales formes de
démocratie consiste en trois
distinctions tout d'abord la distinction
la plus importante oppose les démocratie
directe et indirecte la démocratie est
dit direct lorsque le peuple gouverne
directement c'est à dire sans
intermédiaire elle correspond donc à ce
que j'ai appelé la définition idéaliste
de la démocratie car c'est l'ensemble
des citoyens qui décident
l'exemple emblématique et la démocratie
athénienne du vième siècle avant
jésus-christ sous périclès l'homme
politique associée à ce régime les
citoyens se réunissent tous les dix
jours en assemblée l'ecclesia pour
discuter des affaires importantes et
voter les lois ils sont libres de
proposer des amendements sur les projets
de loi et leur temps de parole est
équitablement réparti périclès a
également réformé le système pour
favoriser la participation des plus
pauvres ou de ceux vivant le plus à
l'écart en introduisant le mr est mis
sth os signifie salaires une indemnité
journalière de présence
nul n'est gêné par la pauvreté ni par
l'obscurité de sa condition sociale s'il
peut rendre des services à la cité a dit
perry classe tel qu'il a été cité par
l'historien thucydide dans la guerre du
péloponnèse
comme les citoyens athéniens sont tirés
au sort pour occuper les fonctions ils
ont tous une chance égale de les occuper
certains d'entre eux sont ainsi
magistrats et veille à l'exécution des
lois d'autres sont à l'origine des
propositions de projets de loi et
d'autres encore vote ces lois cette
participation à la décision ne
concernait toutefois qu'une petite
minorité de la population atteignait
environ 15% qui possédait la citoyenneté
car les femmes les métèques des esclaves
en étaient exclues en outre il était
plus difficile pour les ruraux et les
plus pauvres de se rendre au sein de la
cités pour s'impliquer
l'exemple moderne de démocratie directe
le plus connu est celui de la suisse
même si son régime est plutôt semis
direct en pratique les citoyens élisent
des représentants aux différents
conseils à l'échelon de la commune du
canton et de la confédération
ce qui rend le régime en partie
indirecte mais les citoyens peuvent
aussi approuver des lois ou des
modifications de la constitution décidée
par les conseils par le biais du
référendum ou encore proposer eux-mêmes
de nouvelles règles par le biais de
l'initiative populaire un exemple qui a
marqué les esprits hors du pays et
l'initiative populaire contre la
construction des minarets les tours des
mosquées initiative qui a été approuvée
à la fin 2009 voici pour la démocratie
directe la démocratie est ensuite dit
indirects ou représentative lorsque les
citoyens délègue le soin de gérer le
destin collectif à des représentants
élus elle correspond donc à ce que j'ai
appelé la définition un réaliste de la
démocratie car le pouvoir de décision
revient à une minorité restreinte de
dirigeants choisis par la majorité des
citoyens
la plupart des grandes démocraties
occidentales sont indirects c'est par
exemple le cas de la cinquième
république française même si ce régime
est en partie directe grâce à l'outil du
référendum prévu par l'article 3 de la
constitution de 1958 la souveraineté
nationale appartient au peuple qui
l'exercé par ses représentants et par la
voie du référendum
une autre distinction importante oppose
de deux types de démocratie indirecte
les politistes distingue le régime
parlementaire dans ce cas le parlement
prédomine ce qui réduit le pouvoir de la
personne qui se trouve à la tête de
l'état le roi dans une monarchie le
président dans une république ainsi ce
régime favorise le pouvoir législatif
par rapport au pouvoir exécutif
c'est par exemple le cas au royaume uni
ou en allemagne
second type de régime le régime
présidentiel la personne qui se trouve à
la tête de l'état a un rôle important le
président américain par exemple ainsi ce
régime favorise le pouvoir exécutif par
rapport au pouvoir législatif et
approfondirait cette distinction dans la
leçon sur les régimes politiques
enfin troisième et dernière distinction
importante
elle oppose les démocraties populaires
et pluraliste la démocratie dite
populaire ou réelle et le modèle
démocratique des régimes d'inspiration
marxiste essentiellement l'urss et la
chine l'idée qui transparaît dans le nom
et que ce modèle est lui véritablement
connecté au peuple en vertu de quoi il
est fidèle à l'idéal démocratique cette
prétention découle de la critique de la
démocratie existantes par karl marx il
la qualifie de démocratie bourgeoise car
il s'agit en réalité à ses yeux d'une
organisation de la vie collective et
imaginé par la classe dominante la
bourgeoisie pour imposer sa domination
la prétendue égalité et les prétendus
droits politiques des prolétaires sont
de la poudre aux yeux il n'empêche pas
les capitalistes d'exploiter les
ouvriers comme des esclaves dans les
usines seulement dans les faits la
dimension démocratique des régimes
d'inspiration marxiste est douteuse pas
de partis pas d'élections pluralistes et
des dirigeants qui justifie la
légitimité de leurs décisions en les
disant conforme au sens commun du peuple
la démocratie dite pluraliste se
caractérise elle par la coexistence de
diverses opinions dans le débat
politique ce qui se traduit au niveau
institutionnel par l'existence de divers
partis qui sont en concurrence pour
accéder au pouvoir les démocraties qui
appartenaient au bloc de l'ouest lors de
la guerre froide était pluraliste un
faits illustrent leurs différences par
rapport aux démocraties populaires il
existait des mouvements communistes dans
les systèmes politiques occidentaux même
s'ils ont parfois subi l'oppression de
ses systèmes comme cela fut le cas aux
états unis avec le mac artiste au début
des années 1950 en revanche aucun
mouvement politique ne pouvait se
réclamer des démocraties capitalistes
dans les démocraties populaires
quelles sont les limites de la
démocratie la démocratie nous apparaît
aujourd'hui en occident comme une
évidence elle serait le meilleur régime
politique le seul véritablement
légitimes au point que certains comme
jacques attali affirment tous vertement
que toute thèse qui remettent en cause
la démocratie n'a plus sa place dans le
débat public cette confiance en la
démocratie tend à réduire les critiques
au silence mais cela n'atteint pas le
bien fondé de certaines critiques voici
en synthèse les principaux arguments
contre la démocratie
tout d'abord l'incompétence du peuple la
démocratie présuppose que le peuple
c'est à dire l'ensemble des citoyens
puissent prendre de bonnes décisions or
cela est douteux platon stigmatiser déjà
dans la république l'irrationalité du
peuple animé par l'apparence le préjugé
et la passion et il l'opposait à la
rationalité du philosophe lui armé de la
connaissance du vrai et de l'expérience
les politistes américain de la seconde
moitié du 20e siècle parleront de
l'incompétence politique de l'électeur
qu il quantifie rond grâce aux sondages
le fait qu'ils te lèves soit parvenu au
pouvoir en allemagne en ayant remporté
les élections législatives de 1932 est
souvent invoquée pour illustrer la
faillibilité de la démocratie le
meilleur argument contre la démocratie
est une conversation de cinq minutes
avec l'électeur moyen a dit winston
churchill
certains partisans de la démocratie et
rétorque que le peuple peut être
compétent mais qu'il est maintenu dans
l'incompétence par les élites noam
chomsky avance par exemple d'en
comprendre le pouvoir que si l'électeur
moyen s'intéresser au jeu politique
comme il s'intéresse à son sport favori
c'est à dire en y consacrant du temps et
sans ressentir le syndrome de
l'imposteur alors il aurait un avis
éclairé
autre argument contre la démocratie la
démagogie l'incompétence pour parler
poliment ou du peuple et le fait qu'il
obéisse à l'émotion plutôt qu'à la
raison cela favorise un certain type
d'homme politique les démagogues issus
des mots grec dêmos le peuple et agogos
âgées aux geo est ce qui signifie qu'ils
guident qui attire la démagogie et le
fait de séduire le peuple considéré le
plus souvent sous la forme d'une foule
en lui disant ce qu'il a envie
d'entendre en clair il s'agit de
manipuler la masse en jouant sur ses
ressorts émotionnels plutôt que de lui
dire la vérité et de lui proposer des
solutions réalistes et efficaces la
désignation de boucs émissaires les
étrangers les pauvres les riches et c
est par exemple un ingrédient typique
d'un discours démagogique
autre argument contre la démocratie
l'impossibilité pratique comme je l'aï
déjà évoqué l'idéal démocratique que le
peuple participe activement et
directement au pouvoir cet idéal
apparaît difficile à réaliser il ya
plusieurs difficultés pratiques à ce que
le grand nombre gouverne tels que la
réunion des citoyens l'enregistrement
des décisions ou encore la fréquence des
prises de décision c'est pourquoi dans
les faits c'est toujours le petit nombre
qui gouverne c'était d'ailleurs déjà le
cas dans la démocratie directe
athénienne il est contre l'ordre naturel
que le grand nombre gouverne et que le
petit soit gouverné on ne peut imaginer
que le peuple reste incessamment
assemblée pour vaquer aux affaires
publiques écrit rousseau dans du contrat
social
autre argument contre la démocratie
l'inefficacité comme je voulais
expliquer en définissant la démocratie
elle tire sa légitimité du fait que le
pouvoir politique émane du peuple c'est
le sens de la locution par le peuple
elle ne tire donc pas sa légitimité en
tant que régime politique de sa haute
capacité à résoudre les problèmes au
contraire même elle tend à sacrifier
l'efficacité à la légitimité en
favorisant le débat la limitation des
pouvoirs le contrôle la révision voire
l'annulation des décisions elle peut
accoucher de l'impuissance dans les
faits l'ampleur du problème varie selon
les modalités de fonctionnement du
régime démocratique par exemple la
quatrième république française qui a
duré de 1946 à 1958 cette république
représente une forme d'impuissance
démocratique du aux incessants
revirements d'alliance entre les parties
tandis que la cinquième république a été
imaginé par le général de gaulle
précisément pour dépasser cette
impuissance et enfin dernier argument
contre la démocratie
la dérive oligarchique cet argument
consiste à dire que dans la démocratie
représentative
les représentants oublie progressivement
qu'ils sont censés traduire la volonté d
représentés et agir dans l'intérêt des
représentés il en vient alors à former
une petite classe de dirigeants qui
monopolise le pouvoir politique et
l'exercent dans leur propre intérêt la
démocratie représentative muterait donc
en une oligarchie c'est à dire une forme
de gouvernement ou un petit nombre de
personnes détiennent l'autorité le
controversé militants politiques
français etienne chouard qui est un des
partisans les plus actifs de la
démocratie directe et yale choix affirme
que le concept de la démocratie
représentative est un oxymore dans la
mesure où la représentation empêche le
peuple de décider par lui-même il voit
dans le tirage au sort la solution qui
empêche la démocratie de dérivés en
oligarchie
qu'est ce que la droite et la gauche je
vais d'abord vous raconter l'origine
historique du clivage droite gauche et
de cette diffusion dans le monde je vous
expliquerai ensuite comment son sens et
idéologique à évoluer jusqu'à
aujourd'hui enfin j'étudierai la
question de savoir si le clivage droite
gauche est toujours pertinent en
m'intéressant aux arguments des deux
côtés du débat
quelle est l'origine historique du
clivage droite gauche le clivage droite
gauche n'est lors de la révolution
française ils s'expliquent précisément
par la localisation des partis
politiques dans l'assemblée des états
généraux de 1789 en particulier lors des
débats concernant le poids de l'autorité
royale par rapport à l'assemblée
populaire dans la future constitution
les partis soutenant le roi composé
majoritairement de nobles et d'hommes
d'église sont alors situé à droite du
président de l'assemblée ce sont les
places d'honneur car le côté droit à une
valeur positive dans la culture
occidentale l'adjectif droit qualifie
par exemple un individu qui respecte les
règles de la morale on parle aussi de la
droiture morale en revanche le côté
gauche a une connotation péjorative
l'adjectif gauche signifie par exemple
maladroit à gauche du président de
l'assemblée on trouve donc les partis
qui veulent abolir l'ordre monarchique
composée d'individus du tiers état ce
clivage droite gauche a perduré dans les
assemblées française après la révolution
car le pays a longtemps hésité entre la
république et la monarchie le clivage a
été particulièrement sensible lors de la
restauration de 1814 1830 lorsque la
france est redevenu monarchique à la fin
de l' empire napoléonien les partisans
du roi était toujours à droite à gauche
ont trouvé les héritiers de la
révolution française ainsi que ceux de
l' empire napoléonien à la fin du 19e
siècle les partis politiques se créent
en france à partir de ce clivage
le clivage s'est ensuite répandue hors
de france la grande influence de la
révolution française a entraîné la
transplantation de la division droite
gauche dans les assemblées des autres
pays d'europe et même en russie au 19e
siècle au royaume uni par exemple les
partis conservateurs et libéraux sont
les héritiers des théorise théorie es et
des wings w achi gs qui s'oppose depuis
le xviie siècle au cours duquel ont eu
lieu les deux révolutions anglaise et
ils s'opposent sur la question des
pouvoirs respectifs du roi et du
parlement l'autorisation les partisans
du roi et les wings demande le
renforcement du parlement le clivage
révolutionnaires français s'est même
imposé en amérique même s'il n'a pas le
même sens idéologique aux états unis
puis il s'est imposé dans les pays
décolonisés au 20e siècle
quel est le sens du clivage droite
gauche en france son sens a
progressivement évolué depuis la
révolution française il s'est déplacé
sur de nouvelles questions sur le plan
historique le clivage droite gauche a eu
trois sens différent premier sens lors
de la révolution française et comme je
viens de vous l'expliquer le clivage
porte sur la question du pouvoir
politique du roi dans le nouveau régime
la droite souhaite que le roi continue
de peser dans les décisions notamment
par l'intermédiaire d'un droit de veto
tandis que la gauche s'y opposent
deuxième séance historique depuis grosso
modo la seconde moitié du 19e siècle le
clivage se déporte sur la question du
rapport entre l'état et l'église la
droite est animé par les catholiques qui
souhaitent le maintien de l' influence
de l'église dans la société française
tandis que la gauche est animé par les
partisans de la laïcité qui obtiendront
notamment la séparation de l'église et
de l'état par la loi du 9 décembre 1905
et enfin troisième et dernier sens
historique depuis grosso modo
l'entre-deux-guerres mais le déplacement
a commencé avec la révolution
industrielle au 19e siècle le clivage se
portent désormais sur la dimension
économique de l'organisation de la
société la droite est principalement
capitaliste est opposé à l'intervention
de l'état la gauche quant à elle est
critique du capitalisme est favorable à
l'intervention de l'état des hommes
politiques keynésien comme dominique
strauss kahn par exemple sont classés à
gauche on peut ajouter qu'un clivage
culturel se surajoute aux clivages
économiques grosso modo depuis la
révolution culturelle des années 1960
les partisans de la libération ou
libéralisation des moeurs sont à gauche
les opposants sont à droite la question
du mariage homosexuel légalisé en 2013 à
illustrer ce clivage culturel je n'aime
pas les riches avait déclaré le candidat
socialiste françois hollande lors de la
campagne présidentielle de 2012 françois
hollande n'a certes pas été un président
révolutionnaire ni même gouverner à la
gauche de la gauche mais cette
déclaration était un marqueur
idéologique fort
est il possible de synthétiser ces
différents sens dans un clivage
fondamental sur le plan philosophique on
peut dire que le clivage droite gauche
portent essentiellement sur la question
de la nature de l'ordre social la droite
pense que l'ordre social et naturel
c'est à dire que l'organisation de la
société doit suivre des règles pré
existante qui relèvent de l'ordre des
choses comme la gravité ou les saisons
la gauche pense elle que l'ordre social
est artificielle c'est à dire que ce
sont les hommes eux mêmes qu'ils
imaginent les règles de l'organisation
de la société toute utopie et donc par
définition de gauche l'ordre naturel est
souvent assimilée à la tradition au sens
de limitation des générations passées et
ses partisans sont les conservateurs
l'ordre artificielle est souvent
assimilée à la raison qui amène à douter
et à améliorer et ses partisans sont les
progressistes la distinction entre
l'ordre naturel et l'ordre artificiel
permet même de comprendre le sens des
extrêmes l'extrême droite est ultra
conservatrice d'où par exemple sa
défense de la pureté ethnique ou encore
le projet nazis de revenir aux valeurs
des prétendus ancêtres antédiluvien des
allemands les à rien l'extrême gauche
est elle révolutionnaire elle imagine
rebâtir la société sur des bases
nouvelles
le clivage droite gauche est il dépassé
pour faire simple je vais vous présenter
trois arguments en faveur de la thèse
selon laquelle le clivage droite gauche
est dépassé puis trois arguments contre
cette thèse je me concentre sur la
situation de la france disons depuis la
fin des trente glorieuses parce qu'il
serait bien trop compliqué de répondre à
la question pour une multitude de pays
le clivage paraît dépassée pour les
raisons suivantes première raison
l'avènement d'une société de classes
moyennes réduit les tensions politiques
il se traduit par l'émergence d'un gros
bloc majoritaire de citoyens dont le
souci principal est de préserver leur
confort quotidien en cela ils sont
conservateurs tout en garantissant le
progrès continu de leur bien-être en
cela ils sont progressistes telle est la
thèse développée par l'ancien président
de la cinquième république française
valéry giscard d'estaing en 1984 dans
deux français sur trois l'opposition de
la droite et de la gauche n'a plus de
valeur dans une société dominée par la
classe moyenne c'est pourquoi il faut
jeu le site gouverner au centre
deuxième argument le clivage idéologique
majeur serait désormais la
mondialisation entendue au sens
principalement économique une partie des
français et plus généralement des
citoyens en occident consentent à
l'accélération des flux de marchandises
de capitaux et d'hommes qui a cours
depuis les années 1980 et qui rendent
notamment plus difficile d'organiser la
vie collective à l'échelle de la nation
six citoyens sont schématiquement
représenté par le centre ainsi que par
les ailes modérée de la droite et de la
gauche l'autre partie des citoyens on
rend la mondialisation et souvent aussi
l'union européenne responsable des
malheurs de la société elle dénoncé par
exemple les délocalisations la perte de
souveraineté nationale ou encore
l'immigration de masse elle est
schématiquement représenté par les
partis extrêmes de plus en plus qualifié
de populiste ainsi que par ce qu'on
appelle la droite de la droite et la
gauche de la gauche
la mondialisation consiste à fabriquer
des esclaves pour vendre à des chômeurs
a dit marine le pen qui est la figure
politique de référence de l'extrême
droite française
troisième et dernier argument le
développement de la technocratie c'est à
dire le fait que le pouvoir soit exercée
par des experts qui font de leurs
décisions sur des données techniques
plutôt que sur leurs sensibilités
idéologiques
cette évolution contribuerait à mettre
le clivage droite gauche à
l'arrière-plan ainsi il n'y aurait plus
les idées de droite et les idées de
gauche mais les solutions qui
fonctionnent et celles qui ne
fonctionnent pas dans les faits les
gouvernements semblent de moins en moins
partisan nicolas sarkozy avait innové en
2007 en nommant des ministres
d'ouverture le plus emblématique étant
probablement le socialiste bernard
kouchner au ministère des affaires
étrangères françois hollande lui même
énarque a mis en place des gouvernements
particulièrement technocratique et enfin
emmanuel matheron qui se dit pourtant de
gauche a donné des ministères à des
hommes politiques de droite
voici maintenant les raisons pour
lesquelles le clivage droite gauche
paraît toujours pertinents tout d'abord
le poids de l'état dans l'économie
française fait perdurer le clivage
droite gauche sur la question de
l'interventionnisme la gauche et pour la
droite contre le paramètre de la
fiscalité est emblématique à cet égard
d'un côté la droite dénonce l' enfer
fiscal français de l'autre la gauche
dénonce la triche et l'optimisation
deuxième argument le prolongement de la
libération des moeurs qui a commencé
dans les années 1960 fait perdurer le
clivage culturel la gauche dit
libertaire est favorable à ce que
l'organisation de la vie collective
s'adapte aux nouveaux modes de vie ainsi
qu'à la diversité des identités
individuelles la droite elle s'oppose
aux bouleversements des modèles
traditionnels en particulier celui de la
famille troisième et dernier argument
qui est un peu plus technique si le
clivage droite gauche et peut-être moins
pertinent au niveau de l'offre politique
ce que proposent les hommes politiques
il demeure en revanche pertinent au
niveau de la demande politique c'est à
dire au niveau des croyances et des
souhaits des électeurs les enquêtes du
cevipof ceb ipo f qui le centre de
recherches politiques de sciences po les
enquêtes du cevipof de la fin d année
2010 montre que moins de 10% des
citoyens français ne savent pas dire
s'ils sont de droite ou de gauche et que
ce positionnement idéologique est un
marqueur profond de l'identité sociale
d'un individu
alors la vidéo vous a plu j'espère que
oui je vous rappelle que c'est un
extrait de ma formation de culture
générale culture express si vous voulez
en savoir plus cliquez sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant en haut à droite de
la vidéo ou bien sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo voila
voila comme d'habitude n'hésitez pas à
m'écrire dans les commentaires et puis
surtout n'oubliez pas que vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous prendre la tête pour
vous cultiver